this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
hello my name is Aaron today and I'm
here with the one the only Mister Andrew
flash cor but it doesn't matter what my
name is what matters is who's in this
film and that is the rock sorry I had to
get that out it's the wrestling fan in
me it's okay I'm a wrestling fan at
heart too this is going to be Rampage
beer watching today starring what he
said the one the only Mr Dwayne The Rock
Johnson you guys leave a like on this
video subscribe hit that notification
Bell thank you so much to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
fulllength Reaction watch alongs where
you can sync up with your own copy
available for you super sexy rejects or
over on patreon Greg and John cover
several shows over there with exclusive
highlights and watch alongs included for
you I like Dwayne The Rock Johnson he
likes Dwayne The Rock Johnson so we're
going to see what this movie's all about
y'all are you guys ready are you ready
I'm ready I'm so ready I'm going to
raise my
eyebrow I don't know how to raise my
eyebrow you got to practice in the
mirror just eyebrow raises all right
we're ready to get
rampaged yeah my only experience with
this I did play the video game just a
couple times from my recollection the
N64 game but it was so long ago I almost
don't remember I just remember
destroying some buildings yeah I
remember seeing the boxes like wow it
was like a fun
[Music]
game this is control we have negative
copy on that last transmission we are sh
in the command mod oh no Miss control
this is Atkins the crew is dead reroute
to the lab and secure the canisters
before departure but the test subject is
loose the test subject is a wrap not
anymore whoa W what a way to start a
movie just suck you right in
what is this you have your orders doctor
open the goddamn door Dr Atkins it's CLA
widen we'll unlock the escape capsule
when you secure the samples that's cold
either you come home with my research or
you don't come home at all damn wow was
so messed up I know but she's got to go
in there and deal with priorities am I
right however big the rat is that we saw
in that half a second it passed the
camera take it
down
oh is that a hand just
floating Mission Control securing the
samples now copy that I hope she quits
after this got to slap them first and
then quit if she's able to survive this
right that's priority number one get
that that clean slap in warning integ
critical
oh ooh
Dam what the what the porcupine
rat nope nope nope one no part of that
no thank you he's going to break he's
going to break in no hope not oh good
escape with her though I hope not that'
be really
sad almost had some alien Vibes to it
like it Andrew who's that actress
believe that's Marley Shelton who's in
The Sandlot scream four scream
five this is why he's here he knows he's
oh no oh
no oh chick burning up on
re-entry
oh but the the samples survived
though I know that bald head love that
smell brings me right back to Uganda
Huey oh there we go we got Jack qua is
in this what two scream Five actors in
This film apparently now oh wow they
call me L Diablo I know they don't speak
Spanish but they might as well you ever
see a blood diamond yeah no I know it's
about diamonds but it really captures
the vibe don't mess with Mother Africa
you know what I'm another actor from the
boys too the director everything okay
boss no it's not don't move a muscle
junior Here is dropping a lot of monkey
get with these madeup
stories I love the way he delivered that
line regardless if you had any
experience with poaching you would know
that it's extremely rude to talk about
it in front of a lady it's okay I can
handle it well I know you can I'm
talking about these
ladies is this the sequel to Jumanji
Welcome to the Jungle it feels I me
pretty much could be wow Andrew this is
the second movie We're watching together
that involves monkey SL primat
oh right right 28 Days Later right yeah
tell me what do you see the young male
is attempting to establish his presence
with the female he's posturing agitated
sounds like someone we know
right
Pabo Pabo it's okay FEI enu on
station come it's me no that means rock
that does not mean it's
me
good
boy so that means rock rock of course it
means rock look at who's saying it well
yeah I guess that's it is true it's me
he's the rock so I guess that's that's
meta I mean it makes sense if you move
we're going to be in big trouble Connor
do not move Conor do what he says uhoh
uhoh he's going to freak out he's going
to freak
out no help
help oh oh protected
him y buo one Connor Connor it's okay
George George George of the
Jungle uhuh oh very funny very
funny you and I laughing at your joke
okay new guy he no laugh he cried
yeah he looks so good it's okay it's
okay it's okay he's not going to kill me
no he's not going to kill you he has a
unique sense of humor I could it's a
good thing he's wearing the brown pants
it's important for you to be nice to
Pavo he's just a
kid a poachers killed his entire family
he's in your troop now I want you to
welcome him welcome Pavo welcome Pavo
George you and I cool probably did that
wrong I should never have taught you
that stop that now come on now get did
you got to teach him the eyebrow
raise that'd be extra impressive I need
you to protect Papa family family like
is this the right franchise I thought
The Rock was already in that
franchise it's the spin-off
ah it's a really good good looking ape
though yeah for sure the effects are
great that was amazing thank you and I
would love to learn more about those
submission techniques if you have time
for a
drink I'm sure I'm sure she would jez
that's a subtext with the LI bite and
everything subtext for I want some right
she used the word submission that's a
clue it's a blues
clue is that the space or
I would imagine that was the
ship with the samples or I could do my
comic book reference and say it's venom
venom
[Applause]
[Music]
venom very good I visually visually
speaking it does look kind of you know
look Phenom no kind of yeah
oh George be careful buddy oh got that
spray on him got spritzed with the alien
spr oh yeah we saw that rat he was
definitely a lot bigger and filer
looking take your message about George
you okay I don't know what do you mean I
don't know Davis he's in the grizzly
enclosure the grizzly en closure cuz
that boy got
big Jesus we killed the a bear oh my God
jeez do we know who would win a fight
between a bear and a gorilla well yeah
and also too we saw like the rat was
going crazy I was going to say going ape
what
happened I went on
rampage oh my
God George it looks bigger right he a
lot bigger
yeah is it me or is he considerably
bigger okay that was my reaction yeah I
know he's huge he was like way down yeah
before what the hell happened we were
doing our morning rounds when we saw the
burnt foliage and uh wonder how many
other animals were
infected what is it we got to figure it
out
station you done we just lost billions
of dollars Claire funny I was just
singing a song from Watchmen and here's
is Molen Akerman or whatever her name is
a got the research samples onto the
Escape pod canisters were engineered to
withstand re-entry and the American
meteor Society just reported a meteor
strike in Southern Wyoming all we have
to do is go get it back they seem like
warm-hearted people that care about a
lot oh yeah they're they're real charity
cases there's a reason we were doing
these experiments in space and it wasn't
exactly for the betterment of humanity
what I'm Sor oh did you see that the
Rampage video game ah it's very meta
remember that private military firm we
acquired last year that's so called them
Killers or us yeah well he's the US it
kind of reminds me of everyone's
favorite video game movie Double Dragon
where they had did you ever see that one
years ago maybe uh they actually had the
video game of double dragon in the film
towards the end of the film oh really
it's like this is really meta ien having
your own arcade game in the movie itself
I love it oh yeah they'd have to make
some direct reference to it even if it
is in the backgound it's a fun Easter
egg
Hey Joe
Magano don't you mean death stroke we
got to get my I got to get my com oh the
Deathstroke that never happened well he
had one appearance he had Justice League
or I guess I could call him Flash
Thompson Spider-Man are we going to see
Deathstroke versus Black Adam right now
oh right there you
go
another Naomi Harris film we're
doing
what I know I've already been late twice
this week but it will not happen again
wow so we got monkeys and Naomi haris
that's our bread and butter right there
these were Brave and Brilliant men and
women of science were committed to
helping Mankind and we will continue
that work in their honor that's enough
thank you helping mankind my ass yeah
that's what we said dramatic video of a
fireball touching down near the San
Diego Wildlife Sanctuary however it's
unclear if this is related to one of the
parks gorillas escaping the enclosure at
the sanctuary earlier rear gorilla
escapes hold on a second Mark the car
ahead of me it just uh exploded
what yep that was a good improv smooth
I'm sure buy it I mean it can happen you
know it happens you
know
oh I'm sure we'll find out more about
that no last time no further contact we
should C the canister but it was pretty
badly damaged whatever was in it was
destroyed there's something else these
wolves were
slaughtered looks like another one
killed the pack it's infected with a
pathogen Burke I need that wolf Dead or
Alive a super wolf is that a Robocop
reference he killed a grizzly bear okay
he snapped his neck like it was a
toothpick listen protocol says first
sign of aggression mandates immediate
isolation it's what we're doing look at
him I'm looking at him really look at
him he's in pain all right everybody
listen up I need to find some someone
who knows exactly what the hell this
thing is I found
her y I'm a geneticist with enene you
recovered my research sample yeah you
mean this please tell me you have that
tested for residual particulates I
always do that anytime something new
comes in Amy have this tested for
residual
particules what the hell is that thing
doing to my friend uh well I am not at
Liberty he's growing isn't he at an
unprecedented rate right demonstrating
levels of aggression you don't see in
his species come with me if you want to
live last night he was 7t 500 lb this
morning he's almost 9 ft pushing 1,000
jeez yeah he's not B now as far as I
know he's the only living gorilla of his
kind he he can sign yeah he can sign and
he's hungry guys let's get George
something to eat I mean that much weight
he's going to need a lot more food now
oh yeah are you familiar with crisper
it's more like genetic editing sharks
are indeterminate grows isolate that
Gene and combine it with say the growth
of weight of a blue whale the strength
of a rhinocerous beetle you get one
confused gorilla that could take down
jeez that just sounds like a bad idea I
mean it sounds like a good idea for a
movie but a bad idea for real life yeah
splicing I am the only one who can cure
them I don't know how much longer that
place is going to hold him
no I'm going guess about 2.5 more
seconds yeah if
that
everybody back well yeah she did say it
makes him more aggressive this is true
she didn't warn you George stop George
Davis call
911 oh the dog's barking hit
him oh special edition King Kong let's
go okay yes I know you're scared I'm
going to help you
W I always said that manant stop I'm the
primatologist here I look after this
animal it's okay
come
good stand down don't worry buddy I'm
going to help
you oh it's just going to make him
aggressive hearing that noise oh yeah
it's the mercenaries mhm they going to
shoot him he's going to jump at the hel
the
helicopter don't do that don't do that
guys
oh no he's slowing him down a
tranquilizer it actually worked I'm
[Music]
surprised yeah but George is smart as
hell so when he does come to eventually
is he going to trust the rock anymore
even though the rock had nothing to do
with the tranquilizing maybe I think the
Rock's going to be the only thing that
keeps him anchored to like who he is you
think George is going to die or you
think he's going to go back little being
little I hope not but I
mean see oh my God that w is
[Music]
Wolf I don't think that was a Tran rage
one is
down say Rampage one is down I think
that's what he said that was quite a
shot too that speed that's not an easy
target to hit when you're in the
helicopter and that the moving Target
like that what do you got nothing
yet wait you asked me if George is going
to survive I don't see those two
surviving probably not depends on how
much of a dick he is I I see these two
being taken out in the building oh those
two are going to die I thought you're
talking about Joe magello no I I at
those two in a building I see them being
taken out oh yeah no they're they're
garbage people they're going to die
boss damn it you don't get scared
[Laughter]
what they're in a hurry I wonder why
God oh my God that's a super super
beast are you hunting it or is it
hunting you what the
hell I like that they're showing the
cameras are being taken
out
whoa come on get it they won't pathogen
is ding what we designed it to Y maybe
you should have kept it in
space get money that literally was a
video game shot right there first person
shooter yeah I can see that first person
shooter Dwayne Johnson appears in the
Doom adaptation which features a
firstperson shooter sequence Easter egg
Taylor Taylor's dead buddy I'm
sorry you should have stayed on the
helicopter didn't you watch didn't you
watch Predator one clearly this guy did
not he has a death wish or I guess
Predator sorry singular
now where is that
wolf damn damn isn't this PG-13 I'm
surprised they're showing some of this
stuff so I believe it
is oh it has like the spikes kind of how
the rat had the spikes that's right
oh I wonder how long that rat had been
infect I take it not ah cuz I guess the
the size transformation is relative to
the animal itself right well that that
I'm sure that
oh my
god oh okay I guess I stand yo oh my god
oh my god dude slicing it with the the
yo that's crazy damn that didn't even
affect it getting sliced by the the dude
got that uh that super healing okay I
guess I stand corrected you should not
have stayed on the helicopter don't do
that that's how you survived buddy oh no
oh God later
bro I think he's accepted his re reality
or his fate rather he can make it he's
going to be fine he be
fine yeah oh my God I thought he's Joe
Melo that's Joe sorry we we don't get to
see uh Black Adam versus I thought he
was going to survive longer than that
Deathstroke in this I did too oh rip rip
Deathstroke I definitely thought he was
going to survive longer than that too at
least for the rampaging portion of when
buildings are being taken out and all
that
well I think also too it just drives uh
the stakes up and shows like nobody is
possibly safe but even though he's not I
don't know if you would call him the
main character cuz we literally just met
him like about seven eight minutes ago
but big actor I guess big actor yeah
know that's a great way to establish
Stakes though yeah jeine Morgan hey it's
Negan Thomas Wayne sorry guys I had to
hell of a day huh science experiments
falling from the sky giant Grill on the
loose just a kind of excitement we
here at the government tend to notice
feel like he just came off the set of
Walking Dead still got that Negan ISM in
him I said I want to see George or we
can get in each other's faces and see
who's the toughest brother I'm going to
go PR myself right out on the limb and
guess if no one's ever accused you of
being a people
person I'll see you on board load him up
with your
a uh is that going to be able a hold him
for a little bit goes again Davis
SEO primate specialist Army Special
Forces but what are you some kind of
international Man of Mystery I see a lot
he's Austin Powers let cut the
Russell I told you having George on this
airplane is he's on a very powerful
sedative drip he will not wake up until
we wake him up I doubt that at his rate
of growth that sedative is going to
become ineffective long before we're
back on the ground we factored in his
growth rate same as his elevated
metabolism and the increased amount of
blood in his system we're doing all
right that's not a government official
gun you see his gun right there that's
like his own personal one yeah has nice
shiny belt buckle too
yeah weirdos on the internet calling him
Ralph who do you work for well sir I
work for the American people land CIA I
think that's a reference to the game
ohal it's called Ralph again I I played
the game so long ago for a coup just a
couple times so I don't I don't remember
all the Easter eggs and references just
remember destroying some stuff okay she
helped engineer the pathogen that
infected George she works for enery you
mean used to she a
rebel Dr Kate cwell recruited by enene
in 2010 fired by enene a little less
than two years ago why caught trying to
steal company hard drives and did 13
what I'm sure were glorious months in
our beautiful Greenville Federal
Correctional Institute dang she's in
jail
I am guessing by the look on the big
Fell's face that this is all news to him
I really haven't even known each other
that long so it's not like this big
betrayal or anything that's a good point
it's not like he got to know her or
anything right they met in like the last
scene George broke out and then they got
she was just there to help and explain
what was happening to George and not
like sorry I lied to you I mean did you
you don't know this dude can you cure
George or not that's really what you
were there for he feels so betrayed he's
so hurt I know that enene was working on
a countermeasure to the no I mean they
were her samples at the end of the day
so it wasn't like a total lie like
there's a scene missing between the last
thing we saw maybe maybe there was yeah
maybe there might be some delet a
deleted scene or something Kate Caldwell
what is she doing out there given our
history with her her blaming us for
putting her in prison in the death of
her brother okay so that's her brother I
figured it was not her man she was going
to get with The Rock that's why she I
would imagine going to company sabotage
blames them if you have a plan I would
love to hear it I always have a plan all
right they're they're awful people but
it's comically hysterical how how bad
they are so it's like I don't mind it
yeah there's like they're cartoon
villains yeah exactly I don't in this
type of film it doesn't it doesn't
bother me I actually appreciate it yeah
one small dose will stop an infected
creature's growth and aggression and to
draw them here the pathogen also
genetically rewired the subject to
respond to a low frequency radio wave
lucky for us this building has some of
the most powerful radio antennas in the
[Music]
world
ooh turn on the signal and those
creatures will do anything to get here
and make it stop are we going to get a
sky beam do you remember for like a good
six-year period where like every movie
had the sky beam I think this happened
within that six is it yeah
probably I mean just off the the top of
my head I'm thinking Avengers Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles the Michael Bay one
produced one I there was so many movies
that did it tasm one oh right right yeah
Amazing Spider-Man
[Music]
yes man you getting all up in that is
that is that the W oh my God Ralph get
Ralph
Ralphie what oh this this was the one
that was in the water that was
affected what the hell is that what is
it
[Music]
Godzilla damn it's fast like that they
hit it though that's cool gives it like
a Jaws type of uh suspense
yeah oh is he going to hear it from up
there I feel like he's going to stay
like relatively this size till the the
third act then he's going to get like
super big out of nowhere oh I standing
corrected he's going to get big now oh
he's hearing that noise damn is is the
plane going down it's going down down in
an earlier round
oh crap oh oh
no oh
boy oh George like to smash oh smash
damn they dead they're definitely
dead well yeah he can heal though so I
don't think those are going to really
affect him much yeah he'll be fine come
on let's drop in
oh oh y see how strong I am let me just
rip
this all right you have to be thrown
into two situation ow either this or
Snakes on a Plane which one do you
choose I'm still probably choosing this
one even though I'd prefer to be neither
I'm going pick this one cuz he's not
explicitly going after anybody he's just
like kind of freaking out I feel like if
I'm in the front of the plane he
wouldn't get me feel like it'd be
fine I would just stand by the oh
God George put the government agent down
well I mean he is down leave him alone
George now why would you do that why
would you do
that he's going to get you buddy he's
going to rip you to
[Music]
shreds oh
oh damn uh time to parachute out of
there y would all get suck out of there
so
fast is George stuck on something or is
he holding on I can't
tell oh he's stuck on something
oh
get o that's kind of hurt for a little
bit hang on tight
this is a thing we're going to die with
that
attitude be more positive
negative it's perfect
sync what about George save your
Boy George is like the Betrayal how dare
you how dare you do this to me how dare
you save Jeffrey Dean
Morgan oh damn he feels betrayed he
going to be mad at
him holy you're
welcome that's definitely uh an
interesting way to wake up is this that
CGI I thought the same thing I was like
this CG Rock right now well the last
time I saw bad CGI like like that with
the rock makes me think of The Mummy
Returns Scorpion King I remember in the
I mean it's not that bad but I remember
no I think it's just the the cam it's a
weird angle I just remember in the
theater seeing The Mummy Returns which I
still enjoy that film even though the
first one was better but I remember when
the CGI Rock him I was like oh my God I
mean it's better than I could do and I'm
not a visual effects guy but damn that
is yeah you notice bad CG that is not
very good luckily for the most part the
movie CGI has been pretty oh no this
this movie The CGI has been very good so
far it's just that one was a little bit
noticeable where's the body he's escaped
he wants retribution on you you didn't
take him down he's got a healing Factor
he's wounded but he survived tracks
aheed Northeast wants DOD figures out
your animal survived that crash they
going to have questions for you too
thank you for getting this old cowboy
off that plane well leave an
deserve a second
chance like my grandpappy always said
those got to stick together
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is so Charming he
really is you should be in more movies
the gorilla survived the crash the
gorilla doesn't concern me it'll respond
to the radio frequency and come straight
to us you I saw Michael Jordan jersey in
there too I wouldn't be surprised
they're very rich FBI this is a warrant
for a complete search of your company's
records starting with your lab follow me
it's so F how panicked he is about going
to jail you guys rather going to die or
go to prison for a long time I'm I'm
leaning on the dying one we horrified
that was happening out there originated
in this lab we need access to everything
something tells me they're going to
tamper with it and give them something
or if this movie is really bold they
they take the serum themselves and they
fight we're going through the files of
the scientist responsible for these
creatures Dr Kate Caldwell were just now
uncovering all the horrible things she
was doing during her time here oh are
they trying to pin it on Caldwell that's
what it looks like smart I mean shitty
but smart what do we do now I'm sorry
doc there's no we anymore you lied to me
after one conversation scene I am sorry
I lied to you wanted something you lied
to get it you're human what makes you
dislike people so much I fought in Wars
all over the world I got to see how
people really are you know where I found
George he was hiding underneath the
poacher's truck backstory when my team
arrived these were in the middle of
butchering his mother oh they were
cutting off her hands so they could sell
them as
asrg George never would have survived on
his own I'll buy an all like that on the
black Market's worth of Fortune so I
took him with me and what happened to
the poachers well they shot at us and
they missed I laid the smackdown on them
after college I was using crisper to
help endangered species in the Arctic
then my brother got sick doctors told
him he didn't have much of a chance but
I knew crisper could save P wiid showed
up she made me her lead genetic
researcher but what I didn't know is
that every time I'd make a breakthrough
that could help my brother they were
secretly using it to build weaponized
DNA okay I tried to destroy it security
just got to me before I could finish the
job oh man a month after I went to
prison my brother
died damn they did that to her now
they're trying to pin this whole thing
on her too oh I just want to make sure
can't hurt great anything ever her life
is fun also they're wonderful people too
as we mentioned many times sounds like a
plan sounds like a plan it's okay that
you'll lie to me in the beginning now we
we understand each
other
this film is actually really
entertaining it's fun yeah it's fun get
in position to box
the out and moving fast oh George is
with the wolf you've engaged as a
gorilla sir got them surrounded in a
quarry about 30 Mi outside Chicago Al
said to that one in the water is going
to at some point join forces two
different species making a coordinated
longdistance Journey that just doesn't
happen is David shako he's a
primatologist these two know more about
these creatures than anyone on this
planet I think you need to hear what
they have to say this reminds me of
Godzilla '98 where they brought in
Matthew brri they needed his
expertise a wolf and a gorilla would be
attacking each other they wouldn't be
traveling in a straight line to the same
destination why are they going to
Chicago because they're being called
enery must be emitting some kind of
signal to draw them there those
creatures will do anything to get to
that signal and make it stop Colonel you
have to evacuate Chicago H that should
be easy the FBI has requested that you
remain here these gentlemen will see you
after making a big mistake colel well if
they listen to them we won't have a
third act true right yeah where's the
fun in that why would you listen to
smart people who does that I'm a former
team guy let's not do this thing where
you get in my face you threaten me
because I'm going to have to knock you
out I'm going to choke you out so bad
you're going to urinate yourselves let's
go oh hey he gave them
foreshadowing this is exactly what I
didn't want to happen
sleep so what are we looking for well
we're looking for a helicopter but
preferably one that SS surounded by
military personel they probably have a
grounded medac Chopper at the hospital
that's why you always bring a doctor
they didn't take the clothes they didn't
do that that Trope The Rock would was
going to say I don't know if he's going
to fit I don't know he's going to fit he
probably like way stronger in like rip
it yeah exactly well well look at here
stealing the hospital warberg he's going
to let them go I feel like we must have
an antidote at enene that can halt the
mutations you know if we get our hands
on it could be our only shot to stop
George and the Wolf before they level
Chicago throw her them the keys to they
don't just leave keys under the visor
it's like this isn't Terminator 2
Judgment Day we're on the same page when
it comes to widens they think they're
Above the Law and I want to remind them
that they ain't really like this
character he's so fun I love this guy
clear fire like that we talk about the
ah I don't think that probably did
anything I say again we
no
oo oh nothing's
working Captain Evans what happens when
you underestimate your opponent I want
ground artillery rolling into downtown
Chicago ASAP it's time we throw
everything we can at these things and
get people the hell out of that City
yeah they are evacuate Chicago I do love
that they're teaming up with him that's
cool they're never going to get everyone
out of the city in time
you think do you know how many days that
would
[Music]
take third act here we come also too we
got the Waterfront so we know that other
creature is coming too so we got three
we got three creatures three creates I'm
hoping two of them don't survive though
the water one and the Wolf and George
gets to
survive fingers crossed hope they all
survive you mean cuz they're unfortunate
circumstances for all of them I'm just
saying if it comes down to that that's
what I would
hope messing stuff
up you clear if I remember the poster
correctly I thought George would be a
lot bigger oh I do remember doing that
in in the Rampage video game like with
the military damn oh my
god
oh that I'm not going to lie that was
sick where's warthog one inbound sir
warthog one you are cleared out Rog it
that whoa slick move
[Music]
George oh is that the water creature oh
definitely is that a shield it's
underwater sir we don't have any subs in
the area H oh I can't wait for the
reveal what it looks
like damn it's going to be humongous May
is there's something big in the river it
is say the no has it go on
land wa oh it's a turtle is it it's a
turtle alligator crocodile I can't say I
crocod turle alligator whoa all forces
of that thing
now enemy contact holy there a
gator
oh
oh that thing's clearly the biggest out
of all of
them why would you get so low and so
close woof I would do that from a
distance right ooh they can't stop them
we got to get that antidote I thought he
was going to say but I
can in a different movie maybe yeah he
dropped that bomb no not only do you
wipe out half a city but you destroy any
evidence and I need you to drop the
cowboy and get with the program
we just can't stand leaving our friends
behind get your ass out of here it's
like I can't take the bureaucracy here
where two 85th floor lab's in here damn
it it's okay I'm strong I'm going to
break this down webs 30 minutes out give
a take just want to take out five city
blocks you better move I'm never taking
your call
again what'd he say uh something about
the mother of all bond is on its way and
we need to hurry see everything in the
lab is on one system but there's a back
door into the server so we should be
able to access every file I was thinking
the same thing oh totally we have
visitors they erased everything
connected to the project but it's
here sometimes brains is better than
bronze
oh yeah it's like one of those samples
from the beginning right is that The
Cure not a cure exactly R 19 doesn't
revert them to their normal size it just
overrides their unchecked aggression
nice to see you Kate good hell
Claire now why don't you hand those
over let's go that's not
happening oh oh now let's
go it's okay he'll be back oh yeah she
didn't kill him for some reason well I I
think she figured he was probably but
clearly he knows how to sell being
dead yes like the
game get it to the top it's a race now
get in unless you want to end up like
your
friend Oh Boy George is really
big
wa oh man of course of course he was
going to die just a flesh wound m a
flesh wound yeah I thought you were dead
well I think she missed all the vital
organs but uh don't jinx it now let's
get that an come on sa us wait he's fine
I have one for George we give it to
George and maybe he can help us stop the
other two you know I'm actually glad
you're both still alive now you can go
up there and distract your friend while
I get the hell out of here that's not
going to happen yeah n
George what the hell are you
doing what beating the monster to the
gorilla
o that was for my brother yo he going to
eat her he's going to eat her yo that's
crazy tastes like rich food to me knew
she's going to die who the hell are you
I'm the fell that was going to run up
those stairs to arrest you but sh his
worst fears going to jail going to jail
I'm actually glad I was wrong on that
front that he's going to jail you got a
laptop in that bag there you give it to
me and you can just get right out that
door okay this wasn't even my idea oh
God drop on him yep I had a feeling yeah
y that was a lot oh
God oh my God
God this puts Man of Steel to shame I
was just thinking that in my head but I
didn't want to say it because I'm sure
the people have said too many comic book
references from Andrew
already how the hell did we get out this
roof we're going to jump cuz I'm the
Rock and I can still withstand it maybe
we don't have to get off the roof at all
what oh are they going to ride on
George's back off the roof what you do
if you want to fly we not going to fly
we're going to crash we just need to get
enough lift to stay on top of the
building as it falls you know just like
riding an avalanche I'm so um okay
what oh my God this could get
ugly oh
my
God just think of it as a really
dangerous roller coaster
ride
oh
who oh my God I would just pass out from
my stomach
[Music]
dropping just hover enough for it to
land on the building that's Fallen got
to give him points for creativity yeah
George you
okay my buddy his
friend he's back thank God we really
going to keep you out buddy I know but
that nuke is on its way right now oh I
look like yep that that means
[Music]
stop him George get
him escorts are in position we are 8
minutes from Target oh no I want you to
take this humy and find a sa bone and
get a hold of r he's our only shot at
calling off this air strike he's the
only way we got to stop these things
before they destroy the
city that's right let's kick some ass
should have said let's lay the smackdown
on their candy
[Music]
asses like how dare you betray us oh
oh let's
go
Rock like I'll just watch
George
[Music]
oh hey come and get me you ugly son of a
hide inside the building oh
oh nice nice oh oh ooh that was
completely on accident but we'll take it
a win is a win
oh oh a win is a win win is a win one to
go tell me what you're doing here the
anote worked Davis and George are trying
to stop the other two but there's still
civilians and Military on the ground we
have to call off the air strike were
they going to listen to
him rock is like George I could really
use your
help
get him
George yeah beat him with that
truck me a favor would you and take a
Gand Federal Plaza before you drop them
break up the Drone feed on Federal Plaza
it's me
driving oh oh damn dude George is in it
to win it all
right
no
nice oh that'll get him that'll kill
him
wa well
done the Rock
wins oh oh it does have a healing
Factor nice job
George
oh George buddy God I think it'll be
okay
hopefully oh buddy come on take it out
take it out up you got to
move oh
[Music]
no are the key still inside on this
one oh okay I guess they
are oh
no oh you mess with my friend you mess
with me
mother I wonder what he was going to say
before they cut out no idea couldn't
couldn't even give you a single guess
just have to
imagine yeah mother friend killer
yeah something like that yeah probably
that
one is the building going to collapse on
it I don't think that's going to do
anything George is going to get him yes
yes use that
stick ooh right in the head right in the
eye
woo
[Music]
yeah there we go yeah that will uh
that'll do it that'll get
him I think George has had a lot of uh
injuries sustained aboard
me oh No George hey
buddy
don't die George save the
city
yeah you save
me that's right that's friendship that's
how we
do oh George George I'm so sorry Davis
saved my life he saved a lot of people's
lives he saved his too
earlier
damn so all those people would have been
nuked George is a
hero yes he
did oh
George did I just see you close your
eye I just saw you open your
eye yeah George son of a
pretending to be dead you did that
earlier no no no no no it's not funny
and I wasn't
crying we're friends right
yeah oh
God that I like George's sense of humor
yeah thanks for calling off the air
strike the wise cat War once said
got to stick together then find
George here in new home where are we
going to put him New
York where would you put him I guess in
a jungle somewhere I don't know
h
a liting people down from the
build I like seeing the scope of that
from far off that looks cool oh my gosh
yeah
Rampage thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in Ecommerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
collector thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
there a war-winning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team big
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
Express VPN my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com reex and you can
get an extra 3 months of expressvpn for
free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again that was a rampage I mean look
it wasn't like super deep or anything
but I mean I I I had fun it was
entertaining I mean it for what it was
it was fun and entertaining I think my
favorite part of the film besides
obviously the third act where we got all
that action and rampaging stuff
happening uh that really reminded me of
the little bit I do remember from the
video game again it was a long time ago
when I played it on N64 though I do
remember fighting the Army and all that
stuff uh the little bit I do remember um
which again visually speaking I do I
thought that was pretty cool stuff um I
did you know the the emotional stuff
between um George and Davis the Rocks
character right uh I actually did
appreciate that I know we didn't really
go super deep into the backstory there
with but like the little bit of of the
flashback there with the exposition from
The Rock saying how you know that
poachers were there to uh that took
apart his mother and all that and then
the rock saved him and that's what their
their connection between them was like I
actually like I I got the feels from
that a little bit um and you know it
made sense in in the world why they are
so close and bonded and connected with
each other and you know explained their
whole relationship and I I actually
appreciate that was my favorite part of
the the entire film on top of the third
Act of course like I just mentioned but
um what you think of the film I thought
this was the epitome of a summer
blockbuster like it wasn't trying to be
more than what it was it wasn't trying
to be this super deep story or trying to
break the mold in any capacity but it
was a lot of fun you know I thought the
relationship between George and Davis
was something that was you know I think
the rock really made that relationship
what it was and like the way that they
animated the uh George himself was
really cool I thought the CGI for the
most part was not again not
groundbreaking like not like Avatar
levels but like it was really good for
like what it was you know it was savatar
level
ground oh my mind was blown the entire
time it was good though no it was good
and I thought even the the alligator and
the uh the wolf like that looked good
and even the rat at the beginning uh and
I really did actually appreciate to not
revealing the alligator or C whatever
that was I I appreciate that they kind
of went the Jaws approach not revealing
it toward the end there um but yeah I
mean like I said this was fun it was
schlocky it was entertaining and like
you said not super deep or anything and
then I also I I don't care how how
cartoonish and ridiculous they were I I
like the villains in this they were dumb
it yeah and when I say I like them I
mean obviously you know they're awful
people I you know I wasn't rooting for
them or anything I I clearly wanted them
you know their lives to be ended the way
it did I thought that was perfectly
characterized even though I I was like
why are you guys waiting so long to get
out of here when you know they're
clearly coming and all that um but um I
just thought it was just so cartoonish
it was hysterical that I actually
appreciate it and for this type of film
I just I don't know I just thought it
was fine the way it was portrayed the
way their characters were portrayed by
those two actors um but yeah I actually
uh enjoyed it and also too um I liked uh
the characterization in the storyline we
got for Naomi Harris's character
although I thought it was kind of uh
again not looking super deep into it or
anything I thought it was like we were
like was there a scene scene when she's
like you lied to me and like you know
because she just came into the uh into
the the wildlife zoo or wherever that he
worked and she just said hey I'm I'm
here like is he getting bigger and like
there wasn't really much dialogue
between them and then like literally
crap just went crazy after a few seconds
and then they were chasing George and
then then they got you know on the plane
and all that it's like you guys really
don't know really there could have been
more to establish their relationship
like you're not going to film school to
watch this movie you to the theater to
watch it taking your family taking the
teens you know I'm sure this would have
been great in 3D but yeah it was a lot
of fun also Jeffrey Dean Morgan killed
it he was amazing in this great bringing
that charm that he always brings I feel
like he just walked off the set of
walking dead because he's just so
charming and so so oozing with Charisma
when he's out playing neegan so yeah
just I thought he was great uh like you
said the villains like kind of cartoony
like kind of you know they were exactly
what they needed to be for for this type
of film yeah and even though he was uh
Charming like At first I was like I'm
not GNA like even though I'm GNA like
his performance Charming wise Jeffrey
Dean Morgan but I'm not going to like
this character I like the way he ended
up developing and then there was a
connection between him and uh the Rock
and Naomi Harris and like okay there's a
rapport and then they're going to work
together especially after uh they saved
him and then okay I understand like I
actually too need you guys if we're
going to like help each other in in this
type of situation like I'm clearly out
of my depths here cuz you know he he
thought that George he had George under
control with sleeping and then okay
again I'm clearly out of my depths I I I
really do need you guys here for this
situation um so I actually thought that
was you know very uh you know organic in
terms of the way that they all start to
work together so I appreciate that and
again a good good little development for
his character in terms of working with
the rock and aom Harris but uh yeah I
mean uh I I like I said for this type
film I thought it was fun it was
entertaining I think you summed it up
best it's a fun summer blockbuster it's
one of those you know like a like a fast
and furious type of just turn your brain
off have a good time summer blockbuster
film if you you look at it any
differently it might not be for you
right and I don't know what this movie
made box office wise cuz I I was aware
of it when it came out but I didn't go
to the the theater to see it but I will
say I respect the movie for one knowing
what it is and two being this one-off
experience you know we don't need a
rampage two or Rampage Three like Miss
the days of just like a movie just
standing on its own and being this
experiened and like who knows I think it
leaves room for the imagination to see
like what the the relationship Becomes
of between na onlyi Harris's character
in The Rock or what BEC comes what comes
of the new Dynamic with him being so big
and I guess permanently staying that way
between George and Davis so yeah man I
don't I don't think I need another one I
don't know what the premise of another
one would be I feel like it probably be
contrived if they try to do that but
well you don't need Rampage 2 but I need
Rampage 2 need him to fight need him to
go to space fight other big monsters I
was actually surprised there wasn't more
monsters in the movie the fact that
there's only three big big guys I was
like okay I mean probably like budget
wise are like we can afford three we can
we'll limit it to three guys I thought
the George was going to be bigger but
you know I thought it was it wasun I was
yeah I was you know what with the scope
of the film and I don't know what the
budget was like I thought three was fine
and like what all the Rampage and
destruction even though it kind of
happened pretty quickly uh that third
act I was fine with three I mean I think
it would have been a bit much with
especially with I mean whatever it was
like an hour and 40 minutes I was okay
with three if they would have had more I
mean fine but it was easy to follow with
three um so I agree but uh yeah overall
fun film uh and I enjoyed as always I
enjoyed uh Dwayne The Rock Johnson he
was he's entertaining as as as always I
mean he's it's always fun to watch a
film with the rock so what would you
rate it oh out of 10
um uh I'd probably give this one like a
seven out of 10 or something like a 6.5
7 out of 10 I think I'm right around
there too F 6.5 to seven yeah it was a
lot of fun guys this a good time but we
want to know what you guys would R it
yeah let us know what you guys think let
us know in the comments sound off did
you enjoy the reaction did you like the
movie itself what was your favorite part
of the movie let us know and let us know
if you want us to do San Andreas know
the director and The Rock did that film
as well we're down for some more rockage
in our life yes sir all right you guys
thank you so much for watching it's been
a pleasure and I hope you have a
beautiful rest of your day bye
[Music]
guys